(hums)
(paper ruffles)
(flames flickering)
(beads rustle)
(sharp inhales)
(fingers tap)
- Your Majesty.
(exhales)
(light laughs)
To your little victory.
Ah.
(sniffs)
You wonder why I have come?
Hm?
Do you wonder this?
I am not come to offer you surrender,
if that is what you're hoping.
I have come to describe, for you,
your end days.
The screams of your men as they die slow.
And so, King of England,
you seem so intent on
making France your new arm,
so let me help you.
I'll drain your body of its blood
and bury it under a tree.
Little French tree
for a young, very small...
Perchance that is fitting of your mind,
for you to come here.
Small.
And maybe you're...
(whistles)
I mean, no, your balls must be big, no?
Giant balls.
(laughs)
Giant balls with a tiny cock.
(laughs hysterically)
And the sound of your
wives and children weeping
shall allow me to sleep at night.
(yawns)
(groans)
(coughs)
(dramatic music)
Have you heard what I said?
- I have.
And it was stirring.
Sir John, please walk with me?
Good night.
(men yelling in background)